so very
um hello um hi everyone I'm Jin F
currently a post uh researcher at Simons
Institute today I'm gonna share about
some interesting but Simple Theory about
gradient descent so uh gradient descent
it's a um one of the fundamental
algorithm uh to to find the minimizer of
some loss function
and it's uh especially important in
machine learning and deep learning so um
I hope everyone have heard about the
gradient descent a little bit so if
you're not uh if you haven't heard about
it the formula is very simple as shown
him uh in this uh
equation uh it says that to find the
minimizer of a loss function I should
walk towards the negative gradient
Direction okay but okay the the the idea
is simple but how much update should I
make at every step that is how should I
choose the step size or learning rate in
gradient
descent um to answer this question let's
first say let's first check uh what the
classical optimization Theory tells us
about this so the idea is as follows
let's let's insert the gradient descent
update back to our function and uh let's
do a second order tailor expansion and
group the uh group the first order term
and the second order
term now we see that okay um if the step
size eight Heights small enough then
this green box it's must be positive
that guarantees to that guarantees that
I can decrease the loss function value
by a little bit after performing one
gradient decent update okay this is very
very nice and you can also verify this
idea by doing a quadratic um loss
example so you can uh precisely check
the function value update uh at every
step okay this this observations are
very nice let's summarize what we have
seen so far uh this is a uh also known
as D Lama so if we do a small step sides
uh if we do gradient descent we say
small step sides then the loss function
induced by gradient descent is
guaranteed to decrease
monotonically okay and if you run
gradient dist with a large step sze GD
the function value might diverge for
example in this uh quadratic function
case okay this is very nice but uh what
what happens if we run some experiment
in deep learning setup so this plot it's
uh it's uh for learning a um three layer
new network for a 10 class
classification problem and I'm using
gradient decent with a constant step
sides so you see we see that uh okay now
when I use a small step sides I can
minimize the training loss this is
expected from the de Lama but uh we also
see that when I use a large stepsides I
can also decrease the training loss
however this time the training loss is
decreasing in a non- monotonic manner
and uh the later phenomena is known as
the edge of stability and I would like
to emphasize that edge of stability
cannot be explained by the classical
optimization Theory because um you see
the loss the training loss is really
oscillating so it it fundamentally
violates the dis
l so what happens for GR in descent we
say large subsid so in a wring paper we
we proved that
um uh for gradient decent if if we in
the ne Network training if we simplify
the problem a little bit let's say the
model is linear and the data set can be
perectly separated then gradient decent
with any constant step sites still can
minimize the training loss and I can do
a quick proof by picture and uh I'm
going to end we say open problem so
what's the benefit of the largest
websites or the smallest websites so
that's all I have thank
you thank any any
questions the answer to the open
question is
about how
fast uh the rate atic rate uh you can
show in this problem the sutic rate is
the same so the benefit comes in finite
time well thanks
again